now to the latest on the stunning
downfall of one of the biggest names in
cryptocurrency FTX founder Sam bankman
free is in a Bahamas jail cell this
morning on charges he misused billions
of dollars from customers for his own
personal gain it's a case that's raising
all kinds of questions about crypto on
Capitol Hill Scott McFarland reports
that bankman freed was also a big
political donor
once at the top of the crypto World
running a company worth billions
thirty-year-old Sam bankman freed is now
in free fall this is one of the biggest
Financial frauds in American history
bankman freed who was arrested in the
Bahamas Monday and denied bail yesterday
is facing extradition to the United
States to face eight criminal charges
including fraud the justice department
accuses bankman freed of funneling money
from his cryptocurrency company FTX to
fund his other Investments triggering
the collapse of FTX one of the largest
cryptocurrency exchanges in the world
and costing his investors billions they
advertise themselves as really great
platform they've got a lot of
influencers supporting them Evan Luther
told CBS News he lost more than two
million dollars I understand the risks
when I put money in crypto what I am
pissed off is about this con man going
around and spending our funds in an
interview just days before his arrest
Bank been free denied having knowledge
of the misuse of customers money it hurt
a lot of people and
and like that that's on me one way or
another but
I didn't think this was gonna happen the
new CEO is trying to salvage FTX from
bankruptcy testified before Congress
saying the alleged scheme that toppled
the company was simple this is really
old-fashioned an embezzlement this is
just taking money from customers
and using it for your own purpose
Federal prosecutors also alleged bankmen
freed violated campaign Finance law
directing millions of dollars in
campaign contributions to both parties
some of it they say with stolen customer
money Gail
boy's got the more you hear the worse it
is thank you very much